[Music]
all right guys
bang bang i've got preston here thank
you so much for doing this yeah
absolutely
all right you've been doing the we study
billionaires podcast for seven years
uh let's just start where'd the name
come from because a pretty good name
well it actually started off with the
name just the investors podcast and then
we realized it was just too generic
it was great for search engine
optimization but it was too generic
and we were just like well you know we
we were going to do a lot of
conversations around warren buffett
value investing and it was like hey
you know that that might get to be a
little bit of an old topic after a while
so let's
just change it to we study billionaires
and then we can you know cover
whatever great investors are out there
if they had a net worth over a billion
dollars we just kind of wanted to
pick apart how they did it what books
did they read
um let's read those books and talk about
what we learned and
um it was just kind of a you know a name
that just materialized as we realized
like you just can't talk about value
investing every show
yeah we need a little bit more breadth
in 2014 2015 when you guys started uh
it's pretty early
for podcasting still like yeah why a
podcast and not
uh an email or a blog or you know some
other medium
so i was on a we were at the berkshire
shareholders meeting and i was just
leaving omaha on a flight and i bumped
into this guy his name is hari
ramachandra
and didn't know him but he had a
linkedin jacket
and uh and so i just started talking to
him like oh so your shareholder like hey
you know what else do you do i see you
work for linkedin and so we just started
talking
and i told him that i had stood up a
website that
um and the website was just real generic
but
it had all these videos that basically
take somebody from knowing nothing about
investing
up to the point where they're doing like
a discount cash flow analysis on a
on an equity and trying to determine
what the valuation of it is through an
irr
and so like you go from knowing nothing
through all of that and
i think there was uh i can't even
remember maybe like 35 videos
uh course completely free put it on
youtube
put it on youtube designed a website
then that housed all of it and then had
additional information underneath the
videos
and so i was telling him about this
website that i had made
that teaches people about investing and
there was a book that went along with it
and all sorts of stuff and
he was like you should do a podcast and
i was like
i've never listened to one of those i
don't even know what that is
and uh what you linkedin people do you
listen to podcasts yeah
he's like you should start a podcast and
i said you know
it sounds interesting like what tell me
more about i've heard of it but i didn't
really know that much about it and so
he's like there's this guy his name's
pat flynn he has this
show that's all about creating passive
income
and he has a podcast you should listen
to it i said okay so i downloaded it
before we got on the plane we we go on
the plane and i'm literally sitting next
to him on the plane
no way okay so i need to listen to this
guy for some reason there's too much
going on here right
and so i downloaded the podcast and i
listened to it and i was like
holy hell this guy is doing this out of
his house like
this is like the barrier to entry here
is like nothing
and um i just thought it would be kind
of fun
to just you know and
at the time i was running a forum on
that website i was running a forum
and i was having conversations about uh
stock valuations like we're like hey
what do you think of exxon mobil what do
you think of this company or
that company and um
one of the people on the forum was stick
broderson who i do the show with
and like stig shows up on the forum and
he's writing these
these like five-page analysis on one
company
and i mean they're so detailed he's
getting into his opinions on what the
valuations are
and so i was like hey man the would you
be interested
never had met stick in my life shot him
a uh
you know an email would you be
interested in just like doing
you know a conversation like once a week
once a month whatever
we'll record it and then with an rss
feed we can just pump out whatever we
create
he's like well he's like you know
english is my second language and it's
not my first language and see he's like
i don't think too many people are going
to really want to listen to me
i was like stig like maybe they'll want
to listen to you more because you're
coming from maybe just a different
vantage point or maybe they can
empathize with
you know whatever and he's like all
right well
whatever i guess there's no downside to
this and so we
we started the show and we started
having these conversations we started
sending them out primarily to like the
the berkshire value investing type
uh people and we we garnered a decent
sized audience just pumping out these
conversations talking about
this company that company this great
investor that investor and we
eventually you know turned it into we
study billionaires where we were just
studying anybody who was
an investment guru and how they do it
how many think you've done this point
say that again how many uh billionaires
do you think you've studied this oh god
i don't know
uh 150
yeah i would say uh probably more near
the 50 mark just because
there's a lot that we've covered like
everyone knows i'm a big
ray dalio fan right so like i've covered
him a lot we've covered
stan a lot um
[Music]
so do they ever reach out after you do
an episode and they're like hey i
appreciate that
not really no no um
you know like jessie itzler so like
sarah blakely
um we were studying her and then
i had a friend that i met at a different
meeting
and they introduced me to jessie who's
sarah's husband and then jesse and i
became friends and then
he took me on a hiking excursion and so
like you it's
we have had so the answer question yes
some people have like
we have interacted with but a lot of the
other ones
we haven't and it's just yeah it's crazy
uh
let's say 50 just as an easy number yeah
so you're studying 50 of the
world's most successful you know
wealthiest people yeah
what are the commonalities between them
all right they come from different
industries they
have different viewpoints of the world
but like what are the things that they
all share
so i think this was the thing that that
made me want to do this show
was i've always had the opinion like if
you want to
accomplish whatever it is whether it's
investing you want to be a great skier
you want to be
whatever right look at who the best
person in the world
is and don't just like study them but
like really kind of hone in on the books
that those people say influence them or
the people that influence them and then
kind of study because then you can kind
of more inherently
you know understand what it is that
drove them so
early on like with like buffett
like security analysis the intelligent
investor how to win friends and
influence people like
there's these books that he has said
have influenced him
in a major way so we started trying to
read those so the common thread the
first one that i would tell you
is they're just absolute
knowledge pigs on whatever it is that
they're trying to accomplish
so if they're if their company is
you know creating shampoo
right then then that person would
study and become just the absolute
expert on whatever that one thing is
and they're usually well read way beyond
that as as well
so for us we we're like okay if these
people are
just knowledge pigs and readers like for
example buffett and i know he's not real
popular
in the bitcoin community but for me he
should be popular he's a great investor
he's a great investor he's influenced me
deeply
in in the way i kind of view things
optically from
how to invest but um
i i learned very early on and this is a
great example
at one of his shareholders meetings that
a person asked a question
to to warren he said how did you pick
your your predecessors the people that
are going to come and replace you like
what is the thing that you were looking
at
and warren's response was they were the
only two people we could find
that read more than charlie and myself
and so for him like just reading as much
as possible
is um you know and and you go to the
shareholder meeting he has his
his book list of 30 to 50 books that he
read for that year
and then they're available there for
people to purchase if they want to you
know read something and he has like
little notes on
what their what the books were about but
just to kind of show you at his age
yeah how many books he's in now i want
to get him a a bitcoin book
because i i kind of suspect he hasn't
read one
um but yeah that's an enormous
part of the success and it's a common
thread that you see almost on every one
of them is they're just knowledge pigs
yeah do you think that they're reading
um for the sake of reading or do you
think that it's uh like a personal
curiosity it's like what like
that the latter okay so like they say
hey i want to learn about shampoo like
you gave the example
they then go and find as many books as
they possibly can about the topic and go
read that it's not just
oh a friend told me this book was good
so i'm just going to read it without any
kind of purpose behind it yeah
so the the focusing on who recommended
it
and then how many books does that person
who recommended it
like like i have a lot of people to be
like oh go read this book it's really
good
and like i don't want to sound like a
snob but like in the back of my head i'm
thinking to myself how many books does
this person read a year
because if they read one book in the
last like three years
like they're telling me it's the best
book ever been telling me that that's
the book that i need to read
like i don't put too much credence in in
the recommendation
but like when somebody who's who's
reading like jeff booth's a perfect
example like jeff and i become very
close through
doing the the podcast and just talking
when jeff booth tells me to read a book
i know the filtering process that he has
done
is tremendous because he does about 50
books a year
um and so i i place a lot of weight in
that
so that's something that i think a guy
like buffett and
others you know that when they when they
are reading
they're optimizing how they're reading
and what they're reading and it's almost
you know well that's not all but a lot
of them i find read
more of the um nonfiction
there's a few that are that are fiction
but for the most part a lot of them are
non-fiction readers and
that's what i am as well yeah same yeah
what about from like a mentality
standpoint
dude most of these people set out to be
rich or
successful i think so you do yeah like
in
not all not all but i think most
have this uh you know at the end of the
day
and anytime somebody's achieving
something at a very high level you have
to ask yourself why
why are they so driven that they have to
achieve or accomplish that
and typically when you pull the thread
back there's something that
early in their life shaped them in a way
that maybe like tony robbins is a great
example he was broke poor
right like couldn't even pay for a meal
and was like that's it i'm done i've had
it
and like this is not how i'm going to
live my life and and just
then he found uh jim rohan and
um just set him on a completely
different trajectory so like those
those events early on in your life have
this either a fear or a
massive reward that's kind of driving
them towards achieving
that thing like for warren he just
always wanted to have a lot of money
from
even when he was like 10 years old like
there's stories of him when he was
like 14 years old like running pinball
machines in barber shops
and you know the barbers he's working
deals with the barbers so that he can
put
it in their shop like hey you're going
to get a cut of whatever percent if i
can put this in your store he's doing
this at like 14
15 years old and the barber's like so
who do you work for
oh there's a there's this gentleman that
i work for but no it wasn't it was born
like he
ran yeah so like early on he had this
you know i don't know like for him
specifically
like what was driving him his dad was a
representative in congress
um but there was something that that
incentivized him to
try to make a lot of money through life
how much of this is family driven versus
like individualistic so you just gave
two
examples that i think are pretty
different right so warren buffett's dad
was a little bit congressman
uh my understanding of tony robbins and
his family was it wasn't such a great
situation yeah i think he kind of a
broken home and
and uh not very well off um
i do think that i understand that most
of the wealth of billionaires and even
millionaires but but really billionaires
has not inherited wealth right this is
value creation and capture
um in their lifetime but how much of it
is driven by
a family either hey i have really loving
parents and they're together
and so they provide this great life for
me and then i'm able to go on maybe like
a jeff bezos seems like that's
probably his story versus more like the
tony robbins
uh i'm running away from something i'm
trying to improve my life because it's
so bad
i i think it's a little bit of both i i
wouldn't be able to say
one's more prominent than the other um
it seems like it's a little bit of both
and another important point is with our
show
if you if it's not self-made we don't
study the person oh interesting
yeah so like all the walton kids
we've never covered them on the show but
sam walton
we've read his book we've talked about
how he did what he did
and so like we really want to focus on
the people that actually
generated all the the product or service
that created value to society
and how they did it and why they did it
and and that kind of stuff but to answer
your question i'd say it's a
probably a split yeah what's fascinating
to me is i think the story
or kind of the narrative uh around
wealth specifically in america
but globally is oh most of the people
just inherit stuff
and i started to look and the data says
the exact opposite it's like 80
plus you know didn't inherit a single
dollar right um
most of the billionaires outside of
maybe you know uh the waltons or a
couple of like that
uh did not inherit anything um and so
then you get this
world where like actually it's every
industry right like
it is basically the best person in an
industry ends up accruing so much value
and there's this power law dynamic to it
and therefore they end up
uh kind of having outsized returns and
becoming you know worth hundreds of
millions if not billions of dollars
is it fair to say that they're all more
similar than different though
um or do you see no these people are
drastically different they just all
ended up in the same spot on like a
scorecard of wealth
i think when you when you look at people
who have like what i would classify as
like mega wealth which is
billion plus like if you want to grow
that
and you want to go from a billion to
five to ten and higher
what what you have to become is an
amazing capital allocator
so like buffett bezos a lot of these
people
because you're moving beyond just
creating an operational business
and now you're having to take the free
cash flows that that operational
business is kicking off
and you have to employ it in a manner
that
continues to expand and continues to
grow
so you know i i like bashing on mark
cuban so i guess i'll
start there so like when you when you
look at mark and you look i like mark
mark's a nice guy go ahead
so when you look at mark has he grown
his net worth when after selling his
his stake sure is it anything that's
aggressive over a 20-year period of time
not really um why do you why do you
use that as a measurement just because
that's a measurement of capital
allocation well i think when you compare
it to a guy like buffett he's
he's dealing with capital that's way
bigger than
than marx and he's still compounding it
at
a market rate you know the last 10 years
have been a little hard i would
i would argue why i think it's been hard
for value investors
which might be an interesting kind of
topic to get into and i think it all
relates back to the money in bitcoin
um and the cost of capital but uh when
you look at how he's compounded his
wealth he's done it
still even though he's managing massive
amounts in size
um and but when you look at a a person
let's say you're dealing with somebody
whose net worth is 100 million dollars
you're typically still dealing with with
somebody who's very operationally
focused
like that product or service that they
grew to that
and then they kind of hit a roadblock
and it's harder for them to
go through it because they're running
into similar dynamics of like how do i
transition from being a great operator
to now being
a great capital allocator in addition to
continuing to be a great operator
and that's not necessarily an easy
transition or at least it isn't from
you know how i've the people that i've
studied and looked at
the people who are great capital
allocators did most of them start out as
operators and
eventually transition so it is a true
chance i think that's the that's why
it's hard is because
most don't do it from like i would argue
like with our show we start off on the
capital allocator side
and not on the operating side of things
and so it's almost like for for me i
feel like i've done things in complete
reverse
um but uh
you know you look at some of these these
these people that have high net worths
and they
struggle with that transition because
now they really have to to understand it
becomes very financial becomes very
mathematical
you're looking at free cash flows you're
looking at okay how's those free cash
flows
valued versus all the other competitors
in that space
is the discount worth it based on
risk-free rates
and so when you start getting into the
risk-free rates and you look at why
value investors have struggled over the
last decade it's because the cost of
capital is being
manipulated in my personal opinion i
think most would agree it definitely is
when you think about the capital
allocation how much of this is capital
allocation within a business that
they're the owner of and so they're
trying to basically
uh take capital create more production
right or
more value accretion uh versus just like
actual peer investing so i'm not
investing into a business and allocating
capital within something that i own
uh it's more so i'm actually selecting
securities for example or real estate or
you know whatever the asset is
yeah how much of it i guess is like
almost like an internal versus external
capital allocation
uh kind of wealth generation so so much
of this comes down to voting rights
okay interesting so think about uh
michael saylor is an amazing example of
voting rights
so here's a guy who's been able to
retain a majority
of the voting rights of his company
through decades
of operational execution
right and now he's at a point where he's
looking at the retained earnings of his
company and saying
i need to do something with this because
i'm getting debased so heavily
and so now i need to become an amazing
capital allocator
what can i do to front run all this this
hurdle rate that's double digits and so
because he had control and because he
had his voting rights he's able to make
these bold moves
in a way that let's say you started a
company you had to take on
venture money you get you get vote
your voting rights get debased down to a
point where you're really not
fully running the company at that point
the board has so much more power
and voting control that you you have an
opinion but in the grand scheme of
things
maybe your idea for how to how to
allocate free cash flows
gets completely diminished to the point
where you're you're ineffective
you're still in charge but strategically
you're really not
and so um the ones that are able to
retain the voting rights
i found are the jeff bezos
um he's been able to to control the
board really well
even though he doesn't have a majority
stake obviously for a company of that
size but
he has a lot of control and a lot of
voting power to basically
do what he wants and to move the company
in a direction that
not too many people are going to argue
with them and it almost feels like
and we've seen study after study of all
kinds of group decision making and stuff
uh the voting control you specifically
said
the bold bets right the things that uh
aws
bold bet right uh michael saylor with
bitcoin bold bet
um you really need the ability to kind
of have all of the options on the table
to choose from
that's right and the uh almost uh
evolutionary decision making or the
iterative decision making
ends up giving you kind of iterative
results right so if you
hey i'm just going to improve this
product a little bit okay well maybe
another five percent a year
but if you actually want to have the
outlier returns you have to make outlier
decisions and i think that there's a
disconnect a lot of times
uh where people want outlier returns but
they
don't have the courage conviction the
the stomach
for outlier decision making right it's
just well if you improve the product
five percent then
shouldn't we get there i would even take
it a step further than that
so as those voting rights get this
distributed out
and get the base from any one person
really kind of being able to make bold
calls
what you find is that you're the
employees that have kind of risen to the
top within the organization and now
they're the ceo
they're now making decisions that are
much more ego based
in hey let's do this acquisition of
company xyz
let's bolt them on to our existing
organization
let's pay a ridiculous premium to do it
that way
i can say that i added 10 000 more
employees to the organization
right and maybe it's going to increase
the top line and
whatever their bonus is based on as far
as financial
metrics and like you're getting away
from
what is going to provide the most
shareholder value
and and it gets much more political
within the organization because
there's no one entity that's kind of
driving the
yeah i also wonder how much of it uh
paul graham has written a piece uh kind
of learn to unlearn
right it's the whole idea that uh some
people come into the y combinator
program they come with the paul and
they're like
all right what's the playbook to raise
money yeah and he's like go build a
great product
that's right that's right like there's
no like okay
go to class study you know uh pass the
test then move on to the next grade and
like it's not
school in the traditional sense it's no
the best way to raise money is to build
a great product build a great product
everyone's gonna want to give you money
um and so it feels a little bit like if
you're an employee that's risen through
the ranks you've probably risen through
the ranks because you're actually good
at following directions you're good at
being
somewhat political right yeah you
navigated the politics all this stuff
and so then when you take over a ceo
again transitioning
can you go from that person who's used
to kind of fitting within the system to
then
thinking uh in kind of the bold bets
thinking about it
in a much better kind of sustainable
long-term way
some people are good at it not everybody
is though yeah
right it doesn't help that when and when
you get into the monetary policy side of
things
and you look at the incentive structure
of this continual debasement
and this continual consolidation of
enterprise
and now things are too big to fail so
now we need to print more and stuff it
into the hands of these capital
allocators
that are going out there and and
basically allowing large businesses to
become huge businesses
and then when that consolidation happens
you're not able to have
these entities with voting rights to
go out there and make bold calls in any
type of large organizations anymore
that's where i think michael saylor's
you know microstrategy is such a unicorn
of of a company is once you get up into
a billion plus market cap like
it's kind of hard to find people that
still retain
a lot of the voting rights to go out
there and and
and make bold calls and so like when
when michael did what he did i was
shocked that that was what we
saw first i i expected to see a big tech
company say oh yeah we're gonna we've
allocated a two percent um
position into bitcoin instead of it all
just being in marketable securities
we're now
taking two percent of that budget that
we typically put in the marketable
securities and we put it into bitcoin
and then you would really never see that
much of a profound impact
on the company's performance because
it's such a small allocation
instead we got literally the exact
opposite where
you had a person who's like i'm going
all i'm all in
that's it i'm all in and you're seeing
the stock price
follow the price of bitcoin for for good
or worse
and um you couldn't have gotten a more
demonstrative
situation for corporate balance sheets
and you know in a few years i'd say
within five years you'll you'll get a
demonstration on what it does for the
income statement
which is going to be profound a lot of
people aren't seeing that right now
explain that so so right now
it's a balance sheet thing so as the
balance sheet of microstrategy gets
more and more powerful with its retained
earnings like the market's valuing the
stock
but as we get into decentralized finance
and now you can you can take those coins
you can now employ them
through lending right and let's say the
lending rate is
five percent well if he has let's just
keep the
numbers generic because we're doing
public math if you've got a billion
dollars worth of bitcoin
and you're getting five percent interest
well all of a sudden you're making 50
million dollars
of of buying power through lending
okay and if the company like
microstrategy i want to say their
their bottom line after taxes anywhere
from like 50 to 70 million dollars
so now if he can take his bitcoin
position which is bigger than a billion
right and it can match the income
of of what all the employees are doing
you know think about all those employees
that are working their tails off
creating
you know productive labor right and
productive service
um to society and it's it's netting
the same number as these imaginary coins
that are just being let out like that's
kind of a mind-blowing moment
for people to realize like hey the
bottom line of this guy's company
has literally doubled on the income
statement and it's not just going up in
value
with the assets that he's holding on his
balance sheet
so it's incredible to think about i
think he's got
three to five billion dollars depending
on where the price is right yeah bitcoin
balance sheet
the company was a billion dollar
business in august of last year
yeah right so in less than a year it's
now
valued you know what five seven billion
whatever the number is on the market cap
side
and you start thinking about uh what
business
500 to 700 increases the entire market
cap of the business
at that size at that market cap yeah i
mean it's incredible right
nuts and so it takes a bold bet right is
kind of the point
um but i love how demonstrative it is
because if it was a small bet
um you just wouldn't see it in the
numbers like you're seeing it
it's like hey here's the answer sheet
and if you guys want to
you know copy it feel free and you don't
have to do it the same way i copied it
you could do it
as a five percent allocate i mean i
would argue at today's price
you only need probably a one percent
allocation to protect whatever retained
earnings you have
on a for a company what do you think
about tesla
and the way they did it like forget
eon's tweets
yeah yeah just tesla strategy in terms
of
uh buying holding i think it was like
seven percent maybe some somewhere in
that range uh
selling a little bit right before
earnings like just
what's your kind of analysis of the
whole thing so from the beginning i was
really skeptical that
tesla would have been a company to put
bitcoin on their balance sheet
at all like if you would have said
here's all the big tech companies tesla
would probably be one of the last ones i
would have told you
simply because they don't have the free
cash flows that would warrant
such a kind of a bold
strategy and um
by the way that's exactly why i thought
they would do it really
i've always thought that eon
the energy network uh the power wall
see i never thought about it from that
vantage point yeah
and to be fair uh if i'm trying to be as
intellectually honest as possible i
don't have it in front of me so i'll
have to go back and look at exactly what
the tweets were
there was a time where uh i think i
tweeted something and i was like
if you said to me pick the company that
is going to be the first to launch their
own coin
i said tesla or amazon and my thought
process was tesla would use it within
the energy network
right like it's like a credit or
something or amazon would basically
replace like gift cards or something
like that
uh and part of it was just like he's
crazy enough to do it
right like yeah like he has that element
of like
i'm willing to bet the house i'm willing
to whatever now he didn't do that or
he's only seven percent
but uh the way they did it seemed a
little
i i think it was exciting when they
first put the position on
when he sold a piece of it how much of
it was like testing the market versus
trying to cover
you know and i don't even know that i
buy that that's why he's like
i guess it makes sense that he wants to
know how much liquidity if he
you know needed to get out of it but
yeah but would you do it right around
the earnings uh report
just come in and blow out earnings yeah
no it's
it was it was but in short like
the the reason i just didn't think that
it was going to be him
was you know i guess i look at my own
company like if my company wasn't making
money
like the last thing i want to do is go
buy a bunch of bitcoin
and then have to sell it as as i have my
expenses the following month to have to
pay
because at the end of the day either
your cash account is growing or it's or
it's
contracting and when i look at how
volatile their
their quote-unquote earnings are and now
i would say in the last like
year they've started demonstrating that
they can be profitable but it's still
reliant on
a lot of credits and um you start taking
some of those things away i mean it's a
completely different
ball game for the company but i just
i was i was surprised and so the thing
that surprised me even more
is his energy comments and stuff that
he's come out
and the bigger block size stuff with
dogecoin and i'm thinking
and i was talking with jeff booth and
and lynn about it
and uh lynn alden and they're both like
hey he's
he's a huge public figure and he's
learning in public
and you know that's that's pretty much
the only thing that i can kind of hang
my hat on that makes sense is
is that he's learning as he goes just
like we did right
there's a journey right and everyone
goes through it and you kind of
i think most people come in through
bitcoin or mining
or hey i think i can get rich on this or
whatever
and then you explore the entire totality
of
an industry some of it's gonna have
value some of it's not
yeah some people stop along the journey
and kind of get off the bus and they're
like all right
i found my home yeah and then for the
most part most people go around the
whole you know kind of track and they
come back
all right bitcoin is real right yeah
it's weird when you are the second first
man in the world you're doing it on
twitter
but yeah i mean yeah i guess that's a
pretty good explanation of just
say something right like i mean if you
think back how many
dumb things did you or i say when we
were first starting learning about
everything and someone's like ah
let me show you this or let me you know
go read this or whatever like
that's how you learn yeah you know so i
read his autobiography we've studied
elon on the show
and one of the things that sticks out to
me with the whole dogecoin thing
is so he was he was picked on really bad
as a kid and uh like abused there was
one story in
one of the books that we read where uh
people literally threw him in high
school threw him down the steps at his
high school
and like he hurt himself and whatnot so
like he was picked on
extensively and i think for him
when he started you know saying things
in the bitcoin space i mean you know
you know how painful the memes can get i
mean the people in in the bitcoin space
are ruthless
on twitter if you say anything that's
out of whack right or you're just off on
on your comment
and so i think for elon maybe and this
is me
you know psycho analyzing elon elon musk
but
um i think for him maybe he viewed that
as bullying
and the whole dogecoin thing is just
a total middle finger to everybody
online and i think
he's funny i think he thinks it's funny
and i think it's his way of of saying
you know what you're not going to get
the best of me
and you might want to pick on me but bit
how about this
doge to the moon send right and he can
see everyone just
just making everyone furious and i think
it's kind of his way
to it's his way to get back at people
that are being rude or maybe
uh you know just roughing them up yeah
so that doesn't make it right i'm just
i'm just trying to yeah i'm just trying
to
he he's an interesting one um along with
some of these
do you think that they're happy do you
think most of these billionaires are
happy or do you think they're just
rich and lonely and not happy you know
so ray has a quote he said
you can have anything you want but you
can't have everything
and so when i think about you know some
of these people that i've studied
um it's become very evident to me that
you are sacrificing something and most
likely it's your family
and most likely it's it's those things
that are probably the most meaningful in
your life
that maybe are there
for you but you kind of take them for
granted
and because i don't care what you say
like if anybody who has a billion
dollars of net worth
it takes tremendous energy to achieve
that
and um the focus that's required to take
all that energy and focus it into
something in order to
to grow it to that um comes at
an expense you know as an arrow guy like
you can't
do an equation where you've got lift
without drag being part of the equation
right it's a great way to look at it and
so when you look at it
you have to ask yourself okay so what is
it that i'm that i'm giving up and so
when people
and i think it's important for people to
have these accomplishments in their life
i'm not trying to say that people
shouldn't try to
to achieve but um i think when you when
you map out what is it what is it that
i'm trying to accomplish
and then what is it that i'm trying to
accomplish from a family standpoint
and then how can those two things
co-exist
because if they can't coexist that's
failure you might knock this one out of
the ballpark
or you might knock this one out of the
ballpark but you've never accomplished
anything
right and you're gonna have regrets in
your life because you didn't
and so i think that the the managing and
the merging
of and optimizing that balance between
the two
is something that i've personally
learned from studying all these people
and how you know you want me to run
tesla
and spacex and everything else in
neuralink and all
like get the hell out of here no thanks
right never yeah i want to do that it's
incredible
it's amazing what he's done but yeah
just at the sacrifice of something else
that's right what's up guys before we
continue with this interview
i want to quickly talk about our sponsor
kraken kraken's one of the most
established and secure places to buy
cryptocurrencies on the internet
they've been at the forefront of the
bitcoin and blockchain revolution
for over 10 years their mission is to
bring crypto to the masses
so whether you're an og or this is your
first trade
kraken has all of the tools that you
need to achieve financial freedom
with more than 60 cryptocurrencies
available you can invest in
all of the most popular projects in the
industry including bitcoin ethereum
and many many more kraken also provides
in-depth articles
and guides on every single asset that
they list so you can get up to speed
quickly and make smarter investment
decisions
visit kraken.com bang bang to get
started today
again that's kraken.com bang bang all
right let's get back into this interview
i hope you're enjoying it
dalio uh you said you're a big fan of
him what uh what's kind of his story and
what's the fascination there so the
thing with
ray i would have never found bitcoin
without ray dalio
but like period like ever up until a
couple of weeks ago that would be a bold
statement because he wasn't even in
bitcoin so explain
yeah so um because
as a hardcore warren buffett person
almost religious
devout warren buffett person um
gold is just a non-starter
because warren looks at it like this he
he if you own equity
it's producing cash flows like
why would you own a lump of gold that
literally produces and generates no free
cash flows
like this thing over here has the
potential to grow and expand and produce
more
so like like gold was just like a
laughable
kind of topic like within any type of
value investing community
and so then we were reading a book on um
ray dou
in fact it was a it was a um tony
robbins book where he interviewed
money mastered the game i think it's the
name of it where he just ray dalia was
all through this book and i'm thinking
my god who the hell is
like why is this guy so important to to
tony robbins
and so i started digging into why rey
was recommending that you should have
gold exposure
in any portfolio and what it came down
to
was a currency collapse situation
and he and the basement in general and
how
gold will protect you and and ray's
thing is
he's not trying to predict the ups and
downs necessarily what he's trying to
look at is the correlation between
asset classes so typically in the last
five to ten years it really isn't the
best example of this but
historically if your bond market's
bidding your equity market's selling off
and the money's going into the bond
market because it's providing higher
yields for the risk being assumed
and then vice versa if the if the equity
market's
booming most likely the fixed income
bond market's kind of going down in
relative terms in price action
to offset and so the yields on those two
were kind of like
almost like a sign cosine firstly
related exactly they're inversely
related and so ray's thing was
let me take bonds which is a much larger
market cap
and when it's going down stocks are
going up
but it's not it's not proportional like
if this one goes up one this one's not
going down one it's like this one's
going up one this one's going down like
0.2 right because the bond market was so
big so
what ray is like if i lever that
and i own equities proportional to that
and then a similar thing happens between
commodities and currencies
so when a currency is going up the
commodities kind of
performing poorly and vice versa
so the way he would he would organize
his all-weather portfolio was based on
this and then
the big movements of where you wanted to
be positioned inside of that really kind
of came down to
inflation and growth within the broader
market economy so this was like for me
when i started studying this and really
trying to dig into it and understand
it it was so different than anything i'd
ever learned
with warren buffett's style and i'm
looking at ray's performance and i mean
his numbers are are that of of buffett
and i think if ray would entertain
higher leverage he would tell you
he could outperform buffett just
mathematically he could figure out a way
to
to design a portfolio to outperform him
uh which all that i found fascinating
and like way different than
how i had learned so but they have a
commonality in that neither one of them
likes leverage
well i don't know that you can
necessarily say that because
because ray had like always levered his
his fixed income
side of his portfolio so but i think ray
understands
how uh damaging
leverage can be to a portfolio and
specifically because
rey blew up um you know back in the
i think it was the early 1980s he
completely blew up his fund
and um that was an enormous part of why
he became so systematic in the way that
he
that he treats the market but in general
rey's uh opinion on having gold in your
portfolio was this moment for me like
i have to understand why and when i dug
and i really tried to start
understanding it it
created it answered a lot of questions
for me that i had about the overall
economy in the market that i felt was
drastically broke so like coming out of
the 2008 2009 crisis
i never felt like anything was ever
fixed i felt like they had just
kept putting bandage after bandage on it
they kept
pushing interest rates down to nothing
and i kept telling myself like
how in the world are they going to solve
this
right and then you study ray and you're
looking at these big long-term debt
cycles
and it all started like really kind of
come together for me i'm like
holy crap like gold actually could be
very important especially if they get
this debasement to a point where
interest rates are they try to go
negative with interest rates and
what does that mean for the cost of
capital because over here i'm doing all
these discount cash flows
on equities and you're using you know a
cost of capital and a premium above that
for the risk and i'm saying
well if if cost of capital is zero like
how the hell do i do these
these equations anymore right and so all
that really started like really kind of
click into place when i started studying
rey
and why gold was important and then it
was like bitcoin
well what the hell is bitcoin right and
how he talked about it or
no no he didn't talk about it but his
opinions on why gold was important for
the portfolio
because currency collapse
was for me like this wow okay so that is
important and that could happen
and we are in this 80-year credit cycle
and and interest rates are at nothing
percent cost of capital is completely
broke
inflation's a total joke right
and so like gold like for me became
something that i really started to study
a whole lot more which
i was really kind of breaking off from
the value investing community at this
point
did you buy gold during this period i
never owned physical gold
i would always just buy paper gold um
but but still that was a break from
totally break like you know can can you
uh
can you still call yourself a value
investor if you're buying gold hell yeah
yeah
i think that i think i think you should
be able to but there's there's always
there's a religion aspect to uh
berkshire i call myself that but i
tell you there's some people that that
would tell you that
you know i'm the devil of the value
investing community um
i i think labels and jeff booth's really
big on this too i
i absolutely hate saying i'm a value
investor
i absolutely hate saying to be honest
with you i don't like saying i'm a
bitcoin
i like to tell people i'm a nothing like
you should like show me all the
arguments at hand
on like where and like i enjoy investing
i love the math of investing
um you know as an engineering background
like like investing
but anyway like when you tell yourself
something you are cognitively
programming yourself
to identify that you are this thing and
when you do that
it's very difficult that if the
circumstances change
or new facts arise you've told yourself
that i'm this thing for so long
that you feel like you can't make a
pivot or change to something else right
so i think it's extremely dangerous
to say you're anything i tend to agree
with you um
ro paul he uh at one point i saw
uh he had this thread that uh i thought
was very
um interesting now you and i both know
raul i think that he uh probably tweeted
it
uh similar to the elon musk like a
little jab at
bitcoiners and some of the tribalism and
all that stuff uh but at the same time
there's a lot of truth to what he said
he basically said look
i belong to no religion i belong to no
group i belong to nothing my job
is to take wealth or value
and grow it and therefore i'm going to
pursue the
uh best way to do that yeah right
and and i completely agree with him on
that yeah
but we see but we see uh
and frau was here you know we just see
the technical solution
for sound money in a digital space
differently right now yeah and it
doesn't mean we might not be completely
aligned in the future
if he becomes you know a hardcore
bitcoiner and bitcoin becomes a thing
like
whatever it doesn't matter to me i'm
just looking at the facts as they exist
looking at all the technical solutions
that are out there and i'm saying hey
this is all about
decentralization because if it's not
decentralized they're going to shut it
down or
or attempt to do something in the future
that could shut it down and you're no
better than often where you are today
you know you get into the proof of stake
stuff i mean it's
it's what you already have with the
existing monetary policy
do you think they know that the
perpetrator
oh i don't know how they can't see it
like i mean think about it if you're
staking coins and you're getting paid
interest and that gets bigger and
bigger but now you're like controlling
whether that transaction can happen or
not
meanwhile in bitcoin we have proof of
stake people don't think of it this way
but i look at layer two lightning if you
can buy a 250
full node that's your stake right
and now i can route transactions i don't
even have to have coins in there i don't
even have to open a channel
but if you pay that one-time fee of 250
you just staked your ability to
run transactions right no one's talking
about that
instead they're talking about locking up
coins on eth2
for all right let's just two and a half
years all right hold on let's just get
into it ready
so let me put context is this your first
time listening to the podcast this is a
a familiar topic uh lately a very
popular topic
uh bitcoin was created uh it is a
decentralized
blockchain um there was people who
wanted to do things on bitcoin that they
felt they couldn't do
in terms of smart contracts
composability etc about 10 years ago
they decided to then go and build a
variation
of a blockchain that they felt like they
could build in the composability
and the smart contract functionalities
uh the first and most popular one is
ethereum and the idea was they were
scaled to layer one
now i think the consensus pretty much uh
in the bitcoin world is
and it has always been or for a long
time has been uh bitcoin is not going to
scale layer one you're gonna need a
layer two
uh now in the ethereum community i think
people are waking up to the idea and
accepting it and kind of working towards
you're not gonna scale it layer one you
gotta scale it layer two
uh i recently said in 2017 bitcoiners
learned this because
transaction times were a mess and fees
were astronomical
yeah well we've got to fix that right
and so okay let's go focus layer twos
ethereum kind of went through that over
the last like 12 months right or really
like last six months is
really slow uh transaction times and
fees exploded so okay hey we gotta go
figure out a different
scaling solution in
the pursuit of faster transaction times
lower fees more efficiency there's
all kinds of competition going on in the
ethereum world
some of it is other layer ones so
anything from
you know nfts the dapper labs guys build
flow
and kind of a use case-specific
blockchain to something like
matic which is kind of like a side chain
or like a layer two that uh
the ethereum world likes to say is built
on top of ethereum kind of but doesn't
actually use ether as like the base
asset within the system
and then you get things like finance
smart chain which is just like
i don't want to say copy and paste but
pretty damn close of like hey we're just
going to take this we're going to make
it more centralized we're going to
speed up block times we're going to make
fees cheaper etc
when you get in that whole world
ethereum is
being worked on by really smart people
right yeah incredibly intelligent
engineers
absolutely strategists etc they are not
going to sit around and just let
everyone else go try to be faster
cheaper especially they're going to do
things
and so explain your understanding of how
this eth2 thing works
what is going on and then like what the
issues are that you see
with uh some of the like structural
components yeah
and while i'm describing this you have
all these competitors on the side call
it binance
or donna whatever that are trying to
outpace them with their own more central
i would argue more centralized
solution set but they're they're able to
do all these things
that they're trying to catch up with
that's in place
and meanwhile the market caps exploding
right so for
eth2 so you have a beacon chain
so you got eth1 which is what we know
now right you got your
your beacon chain which uh the beginning
of december of 2020
they launched their beacon chain and
this is now how they're going to do
store or
how they're going to do uh proof of
stake proof of stake
the chain that they've got right now
similar to bitcoin is proof of work
okay which in my opinion and i assume
you agree with me
there's a lot better solution uh for
they're actually being worked to produce
monetary units right
anyway so they launched this beacon
chain and it's
think of it like a skeleton that then
there's going to be even more there's
going to be
eventually 64 block chains that are
going to be underneath this the reason
they're doing all this is so that
they can scale it because as it exists
right now
the the size is going to get too big
five
ten years from now it can't scale
so that's their solution they've got
this beacon chain so
to get this thing going they have to
have coins
that are there that can then validate
the blocks because with proof of stake
you're using
people with large position sizes are
able to
validate the transaction because they
have an incentive to do so yeah so it's
important to say like
the argument for proof of stake is i own
a lot of this asset that is dependent on
this chain and therefore i have an
economic interest in telling the truth
on chain in terms of validating
transactions etc so that i can get more
of the coin just like yes so you want
the downside is not so great
you want to understand proof of stake
just look at the existing monetary
system and you'll understand it quite
well
so um anyway so
they in december they
had all these people stake their coins
and the exchanges are a huge part of
this
the exchanges get a cut of the interest
that's being paid well the interest is
seven percent that they're paying
for these these things so i take my
we'll call them eth1 coins
and i now i'm staking them on the beacon
chain or eth2
uh i'm getting paid seven percent
interest and
if i am an exchange i'm not using only
my own
ether i'm using all my deposits that's
right
to go ahead and go over here and stake
it as well well you're you're offering
it up to all the customers if they want
to stake it here's
here we'll we'll help you stake it and
so then once it goes in there
it's not coming out until the powers
that be
released the uh release the tokens the
interest that's being paid
is coming out of the new beacon chain
okay this is the most important part
so in lending you earn interest when you
lend out
your assets in crypto there is the
ability to do
staking or uh air drops or some of these
other things where you can actually earn
yield but it doesn't come from i lent it
you pay me interest right
yeah what we're talking about here
specifically
is uh kind of a combination of a couple
of things
so one is this is not lending where
somebody's borrowing it going and doing
something within they're paying you
interest no that's not how the yield is
generated
it's not really an air drop right
because it's got an
element of um it's the same
system where you put in a
amount let's say 10 eth and you're going
to get paid seven percent on that 10th
uh but where the actual
eath is coming from you're saying these
are eth one coins that are being staked
in the eth2 system
but there's now seven percent being
paid out from eth2 into
that remain on on the eth2 beacon chain
that are coming from that protocol okay
but as so is there there's basically a
disagreement
between eth1 and eth2 in terms of supply
that'll that'll work itself out when it
eventually gets ported out when eth1
gets ported over
okay okay and then all the coins are
going to then be materialized but the
reason you're not seeing that
inflationary impact
um kind of being realized into the
market is because
that interest is being pegged into the
staked
you know address and isn't allowed to be
withdrawn
so it's get so eth one's basically
getting debased
against those eth2 coins but it's not
being realized in the market because
those coins never hit the market
so really what's happening is uh
it's almost like money's being printed
at the central bank but they're not
putting it into the system
and they told people they were doing it
but no one actually understands what's
happening
and then instead it's going to all the
bondholders yeah
in the future they're going to give it
out
yes eventually when when the when the
pin
is released and it's ported right
like all those coins now you know have
been released
with the additional interest then
they'll be all realized at once now
what what you hear in the youth
community right now is this 1559 uh
update where ins the
proof of eip 1559. correct
so um and i think they're trying to do
this in the july time frame
and what they're doing is the miners the
people that are mining
ethereum right now from what i
understand it's very profitable for for
miners
and their fees are high and so what
they're doing is they're breaking the
fee
into two portions it's a base fee that
you're going to pay and once you pay
that
if this if this 1559 goes through once
you pay that it gets burnt
not to come back on the market ever
again
and then if you want your transaction to
get included faster you have the option
to
basically put a a kicker or a fee
on top of that to get your your
transaction included into the next block
so what i think they're trying to do and
at least and and i might be missiling
this and i don't want to misrepresent it
but
um anything that i see online is talking
about oh well eth's going to do 1559 and
it's going to jack the price because
there's going to be less and less coins
after each block's mined
but what's not being said is the seven
percent the basement over on eth2 that's
going to
drop into the market all at once now are
they trying to do this to offset the two
right to to keep the supply basically if
we're gonna add seven percent can we
take seven
to sustain yeah maybe i i don't know
um and i want to be fair in the way that
i'm representing it
they could be um my bigger concern is
like
why are you porting or why are you
staking
coins in december of 2020
and yesterday i just saw that uh
i think it was vitalik announced that in
they're not going to
port until the end of 2022
and from what i understand i might be
wrong about this but i think they're not
even going to release the stake coins
until
they have the sharding set up underneath
of the port which is
1.5 which is happening not at the end of
2022 it's going to be months after that
before they even stand up the
64 block chains that are underneath of
the beacon chain so we're like two years
away
now which is two and a half years since
why did you stake the coins and pay this
at seven percent debasement so soon yeah
cause basically you're talking about you
know almost twenty percent
i mean i don't know but for me when i'm
looking at this okay
then and i didn't suspect you and i
would be having an ethereum conversation
but hey
i didn't either but let's do it but um
when i look at this from a technical
standpoint right
can can this all happen absolutely
do i see a high probability of success
when you're trying to take something
that is a proof of work
massive in size i think the last thing
that i saw it was like
uh 10 terabytes to run a full node um
and it's growing at like two terabyte or
i'm sorry i think it's one terabyte
every two months is how fast it's
growing right now in size
let's think about it as this thing
branches off i mean it's
it's an area kind of equation not a
linear kind of equation
um and so like where's that going to be
by the end of december of 2022 as far as
node size how many people can run a 20
tera
node and at what cost
right um so
i want to be fair to the ethereum yeah i
do too
what i want to say is um
you and i probably see this as low
probability of success if it works
and they pull it off it will create
value for the ecosystem
yeah but the probability of it working
as
we know the facts today are much lower
than maybe the confidence level that
some people are labeling this with
right so it's it's that's the issue yeah
i think it's just like
there's a lot of people talking about it
as like this is happening it's gonna
work
you know maybe not there's no risk but
just like
way more confidence than you or i have
that is actually i'm not a hater to be
honest with you like
i and he started out mining ether by the
way really
yeah yeah i've never mined anything i've
always just bought the coins
but um i'm i'm not a hater on this in
fact
i i actually really enjoy studying the
engineering and trying to understand how
they're going about it
but at the at the same time i'm an
investor
like i'm looking at what's the reward
and what's the risk associated with
achieving
the reward and when i'm looking at the
tech the technicalities of trying to
port this
in an open source environment it's not
like one person's there with an
integrated master schedule and saying
on this date we need to have this
achieved and this is a parallel task
this is a serial task
like these are the milestones we got to
hit in order to hit that day
like no they're doing there's people
that are doing it but there's another
person doing the same thing and maybe
their
their schedules are different and their
tasks are different
and like like in an open source
environment
trying to do what they're trying to do
is
it's extremely hard and very challenging
and they might knock it out of the
ballpark right they might knock it out
of the ball
i'm i'm i'm looking at the price action
i'm saying i think that's because
everyone staked their coins and those
coins are now off the market
the scarcity of the coins right that's
what's driving the price action that
maybe you've seen the out performance
recently um i'm thinking it's much more
attributed to that than any type of
uh technical solution and i think the
biggest concern for
oh there's peter mccormick um
but anyway i think the bigger uh
i think the bigger concern like long
term for
for them is these other chains the
binance the kadar
cardano um competing with them and maybe
offering an even more centralized uh
solution set than what ethereum has but
because
they have that maybe from a technical
standpoint they're able to get these
things in place
now while i'm saying all this this is
really important
this is really important in the back of
my head the thing i'm concerned about
isn't any of that defy like all this the
thing i'm concerned about
is this hundred trillion plus bond
market
that's been bid down to zero percent
manipulated for decades down to zero
percent
and as the price of this starts to run
i'm thinking to myself
if i'm sitting on a fixed income desk on
wall street
i'm ready to like crap my pants
right and i'm i'm saying to myself what
if this becomes
the new form of value right
and you're hearing stan and rey talking
about
the dollars gonna eventually fail like
come on dude like we never heard
anything like this years ago but stanley
druckerman went on cnbc and said in 15
years i think there's a high probability
yeah the dollar not being the gold
currency so where the hell is all that
buying power that's
the 100 trillion plus going to get
stuffed into is it going to get stuffed
into some protocol
that's kind of centralized kind of not
that the monetary policy has kind of
been changing and now
it's tightening but then once these
coins get dropped because it gets ported
there's more
like they're not going there with
100 trillion dollars of low
yielding debt because the people that
are putting it into that are looking for
a return that is really reliable right
they're going to go to something that
just preserves it
like on the spot right and so like
that's what i'm looking at like people
are looking at the price action
in a very myopic kind of way they're
saying hey this one's doing good oh
dogecoin is up 30 right let me chase
all over this place meanwhile their
capital gains are exploding that they're
going to have to pay the taxes on all
their trading and everything else
meanwhile i'm just sitting over here and
i just keep buying what i feel
has tremendous upside and has
minuscule technical risk relative to all
the other things out there
and so from an investing strategy coin
that's what they call it
all the all the people who are operating
at the fringes of innovation
they call it boomer coin which means
it's the safest most conservative thing
on the market
but it's just when you when you look at
people that have
created enormous wealth in their life
they take
giant asymmetrical bets where the risk
is actually just like minuscule but the
reward is massive
and there's you might have you might
have three of them in a lifetime
right and so like that's how that's the
lens that i'm looking at bitcoin through
it's not that i'm a hater on these other
things
i think especially as an engineer i'm
telling you i'm looking at i'm just like
holy hell that's ambitious right and i
hope they're successful i hope they can
do whatever
but for me it's just real easy to like
like bitcoin is just what do you think
happens to bitcoin over the next five
years
i i mean i think the run we're in right
now is about to get
crazy pretty interesting yeah are you a
subscriber to like the super cycle
theory i i am uh
but i don't know if it's gonna be this
cycle or maybe the next cycle i'd be
really shocked if it could go
longer like the central banks could keep
the lid
on this insanity for more than five
years
i'd be really surprised i agree with you
um
how do you look at the institutions
coming into the market uh i think
there's some people who would argue
oh institutions are here they have
strong hands uh there won't be a big you
know 80
85 percent drawdown after a blow off top
in the current cycle that we're in
other people argue uh no they're the
weakest hands around and they're gonna
dump this stuff they're actually gonna
accelerate
a drawdown once they get any sort of 20
30 percent you know de-leveraging and
they're actually gonna make it go faster
and
i think so much of it comes down to what
we were talking about earlier which is
the voting rights and the boards
like to convince the board that they
need to do this
um is is as challenging
i mean i look at square as a perfect
example
jack dorsey is like running that company
but he doesn't have the majority the
voting rights are
a substantial portion of it and so i
think he's struggling to
because i suspect i might be wrong but i
would suspect that he would want to put
more of that
on their balance sheet than what he's
done but i don't think he can do it just
because of the the composition of the
board and what he's up against
so i think that that's probably the
bigger picture and i think
is as the price i think once the price
goes through about a hundred thousand
i think it's just gonna get such a such
a wire brush
scrub of scrutiny as to what the hell
is this thing and why are there people
trading a hundred thousand dollars for
an imaginary token
why there's something i'm missing i
think is what happens
once you kind of get through that price
level
and um and it hasn't died i thought it
would have died 20 times before that too
yeah yeah yeah it's basically not only
does it not die but it keeps going up
higher and higher in price over time
what the hell's going on
what's going on yeah yeah i think i
think we're starting to get there so for
me
if i was gonna say you know i think five
years
is i don't know how they can keep the
lid on this for another five years you
might see it even sooner
um and so for me like trying to time
whether like how do i position myself
through all this
the thing that i'm really paying much
more attention to than bitcoin is just
like the macro
backdrop of what's happening in the
fixed income market what's happening in
the commodities market
oil's at 70 a barrel right now if it's
anything like 2008 by the end of the
summer you're at 150
a barrel and people hearing that now
would be like that's totally nuts
um it's possible and it's possible it's
way more possible than i think people
realize
in march of last year i wrote a piece
and i picked uh four assets and i said
here's how i think they're gonna perform
i said equities i think it was over two
year period if i remember correctly
equities eight out of ten oil five out
of ten
gold two out of ten bitcoin 11 out of
10.
yeah those were the rankings yeah
directionally cracked on almost all of
them
oil and uh equities should have swapped
them right in terms of oils outperform
the equities just because it was so
depressed but i actually look at it as
that's probably
the right way to keep looking at it like
we're a year after right but like i
don't think anything's changed nothing's
changed if anything it's only
intensified
bitcoin you know oil slash equities or
kind of be you know similar but oil
probably outperforms equities and then
you have gold
yeah and so it's this crazy world of
like
has gold failed yeah
well let's put it this way gold has
always failed
there's a lot of people that i'm gonna
get so much crap for that but
uh think about it throughout time
currencies have always failed again
a gold peg let me rephrase it a gold peg
has always failed why because it
requires trust
okay you've got to have a vault you got
to trust somebody to
maintain that vault more importantly
there's a multiple of how much currency
is in circulation against
that gold and you got to trust that
somebody's not going to put more
into circulation against what's in the
vault okay
between those two pieces they both
require
trust so like go back to when we did
bretton woods
right up until we came off the gold
standard why'd we come off the gold
standard it wasn't like we just
miraculously
decided one day we were going to come
off it it's because we kept adjusting
that money multiplier that
that ratio we kept adjusting that money
multiplier
for decades until it got so high that if
people came back with that currency and
wanted their gold
we couldn't fulfill all the orders so
gold has always failed as a as a as a
peg
but but here's where go so so i'm
talking about it in a sovereign way
okay gold has failed in a sovereign
way to protect the buying power of the
currencies that ride on top of it every
time
from an individual standpoint gold has
preserved buying power throughout time
i will say that so if you had an ounce
of gold
today and you had it back in the roman
empire
the buying power that you were able to
go out there and achieve for whatever
you know the difference do i look at it
is uh gold preserves
buying power is up five percent you know
over the last 12 months or so uh
bitcoin grows the purchasing power right
one it one is being a
uh kind of uh repricing of the asset
it's uh
accelerating your purchasing power
things are getting cheaper around you
gold simply uh keeps the prices the same
around you
right it doesn't have that asymmetry to
it that's right and bitcoin will
in my opinion a big bitcoin will
eventually be that correct
right it'll serve the same preservation
of buying power and when that day
comes i'll become a hardcore value
investor
kind of like you know i'll be doing the
you know discount cash flows on on that
but i'll be using bitcoin as
as the i mean i'm i'm already doing that
that's why i'm pretty much in bitcoin
right
but that as that transition occurs and
that comes
to become the unit of account there's
tremendous
opportunity in front running that event
that i would argue is a
once-in-a-lifetime event
i agree before i let you go i have three
questions you could ask me one to end it
uh you're a very very well-read guy
what's your
most important book you've ever read
well uh
this is a strange book so i'm kind of
like how do you say it okay
what is it i recommend this book there's
a book called the seed of the soul
the seed of the soul okay the seat like
you're sitting in a seat
of the soul and this is oprah winfrey's
favorite book of
all time and it's uh
it i would argue and i just i actually
got uh robert breed loved to read this
book
um and he loved it and he says you know
it kind of changed me a bit
and i said well yeah welcome to the club
it changed me too um
but it i felt like it just made me a
better person um
and the book gets into a lot of uh
what are your intentions and kind of
like karmic obligation that's associated
with your intentions especially when you
act upon them
um and i'm going to warn you like if
if you read this book it's a strange
book all right but the seat of the soul
the seat of the soul yeah oprah winfrey
today dude it's it's uh it was it was a
profound book for me
all right um and the other book
um i really like learning about the
brain i like learning about habits so
like the power of habit was a really
profound book for me
um atomic habits is another one
um uh there's a book called the brain by
david eagleman
i think it's fantastic um
there's some there's some other ones on
the brain that i would tell you are
really good
um investing wise
i think you can get this on pdf because
it's not even in print but
margin of safety is probably one of the
best investing books out there
way better than the intelligent investor
in security analysis
um all right second question
sleep schedule our friends at eight
sleep uh i've got a thermo-regulated bed
i sleep on it's freezing cold
i used to sleep like five maybe six
hours
wolves don't sleep the whole nine yards
right like
point of pride this is like eight or
nine hours now i've
loved it completely changed my life
better mood more energy all everything
remembers about
what's your sleep schedule uh it's
pretty predictable
um i usually go to bed
i don't know 10 or 11 o'clock and then
up at six it's like seven eight hours
yeah it's not bad
it's pretty generic there's nothing
special to it but
that's another good book um the guy from
stanford wrote it um
why would we sleep really good was it
matthew walker i think was his name or
something i don't yeah i can't remember
his name
all right third question aliens believer
or non-believer oh yeah
why um i just
when i look at just how massive
everything is and almost where um
when you look at what life is it's just
assembling
and organizing things and everything
else is
entropy and chaos um it just
for me seems like it's a natural part of
the universe
life is somehow part of the natural part
of the universe
and like if you'd go to even planets
within our own solar system it wouldn't
surprise me in the least bit to find
some type of
bacteria or life form that's
that has matured or developed itself
based on the organic substance of that
planet
um wouldn't surprise me in the least bit
and so when you look at all the other
solar systems all the other galaxies
like
i don't know man it's just from a
statistical standpoint it just seems
very
natural yeah i think it's a no-brainer
yeah what question you have for me to
finish up
oh man
i guess uh how you got your start in
this
because i don't know i don't know your
back story so like you're in the
military i know
oh in like in the podcasting yeah oh
podcast
yeah uh i was in the military uh came
back
um i had two like small startups that i
tried to build
uh varying levels of success went out to
facebook ransom product and growth teams
there
uh i always say that uh the pro
like the quintessential example of
showing up being surrounded by amazing
people
uh right time right place you get way
too much credit when things go right and
if things had gone wrong
you'd get all the blame right yeah but
like literally uh could have been a
better situation
i started investing full time in 2016
and
a kid that i had met when he was in high
school uh i was a freshman in college
and he came out to me
and i heard about bitcoin one time
before in 2014 at facebook uh david
marcus when we hired him he talked about
a little bit
but 2016 kid didn't even pitch me on
cryptocurrency anything he was like hey
man like
there's basically this thing called
mining you like buy a computer you plug
it in and like money shows up
and i was like you like prince like like
you'd be like what and so he like
explained it to me and it was gpu mining
uh which is what he had been doing
uh and to his credit he could show me
like look
i bought this this how much it cost this
is what i earned like i'm making money
yeah like all stuff right and uh my dad
had been in the data center business for
like 40 years
oh so when i saw this i was like wait a
minute it's like better than data
centers like
persistent demand for power no sales
team you don't need a sock two tier
three center
i mean like all the things it's like
okay fine and uh the first big bet that
i made was i sold all my facebook stock
and i took about fifty percent of it i
put it in cash and put in the bank
another fifty percent i bought equipment
and
i had no idea you got your startup kind
of well and to be clear
the very first foray was like i bought
equipment like went to a other facility
somebody else was hosting it for me i
had like a dashboard so it wasn't like i
was like doing much right other than
just
uh the cap allocation uh but then from
there it's like okay like now how do i
get started do more
uh and so jason williams i think you've
probably interrupted
uh jason and i met in 2016 and
uh there's this famous car ride that we
took from raleigh to charlotte we're
going to see a company we'd invested in
and uh yeah it's probably beginning of
2017
and i was like telling him about this
and he's like this is nuts like what are
these like fake
like shut up right so you know two and a
half hours down two and a half hours
back and by the time we got back he was
like all right like
but let's like do like this is
interesting and
uh we both invested in a power
generation company
uh and he stepped in as a ceo at this
point and so
uh the power generation company
literally took car tires
and turned it into commodities oil steel
uh syngas carbon etc
and you should have seen the faces on
the people when we showed up we were
like all right we're gonna build a
cryptocurrency mine
here on the facility they were like what
is a cryptocurrency like what is a mine
who are these weirdos just like this is
like wild and it was like yeah like
we're going to take the car tires we're
going to do
the exact same process but rather than
sell that power into the grid we're
going to like mine it here
on site and like here's the math like
you know we're going to sell for three
cents or we can mine it like 35 cents or
whatever and they were like
that sounds like a scam right like what
do you mean you could 10x the
you know uh revenue totally honest we're
just like yeah it's just a different
thing
so to their credit uh i mean we tried a
lot of different things
people were like oh i built a mine like
cool you ever try to figure out air
conditioning and like cooling
and the cost and i mean you just get
into like it's just a nightmare
yeah ended up getting it built and then
that was like uh
while this is going on i've got the
mines running and uh
ether went from 10 to 30 to 100 between
like february and may of 2017
and i was like stop the press it like
what is going on uh and i just went down
the rabbit hole and
here we are wow dude i had no idea yeah
it was uh
i love how jason's involved in that i
didn't realize that
jason and i are very good friends we've
known each other now for a while and uh
we're very similar and now you know dave
portnoy loves him
yeah you can't get enough of them well
because jason understands that you know
people who talk [ __ ] like to
talk [ __ ] to somebody yeah you need
somebody to go back and forth it's not
as fun doing it to a wall
every time he says parabolic guy all
right where can uh where can we send
people to find you on the internet or if
on the podcast
i'm on twitter just first and last name
prestonpish
and uh the podcast is called we study
billionaires the bitcoin show that i
that i run it comes out on wednesdays
and then we still run a traditional
show on saturdays for people that are
interested in the traditional investing
stuff
awesome thank you so much for doing this
hey thanks for having me over this is
awesome